>> I'M SORRY, MAM, WE HAVELOCKE
THANK U FOR THAT UGH.
S.
THKS TO ILATION AND CRI
YINGOUR FAVORITE POR ISO
WELL, JUST LE MEHEN I WA A
CHIL
$4 C OF SPAN A NOWEINGLOCKED II
AND IT'S N JT AM.
W YO CITY STORES A LOCNG
UP BASIC STUIKE TTHPASTE
ANDOAPO KEEP IT FROM CROOKS
WHO SWIPE I AND SELLT
ELSEWHERE. SEOUSL IUST BOUGHT AT
DON'T WORR ISOT ME M PARK.
TEET
AT DO YOMEAN?
A SPOKEOMAN SAYS INSTALNG
ANTITHEFTEVICS IESPONSE
TRANSMITTED STRAIGH FRO KAT'S
ANKLE MONITO
SO IT' THE PERCTYMBO OF
GLASS.  ERA, PRESER ACTE PAEDYSR
I WONDERHICHNEAS A LONGER
ELFLIFE.
THIS I WT YOU GE WHEN THE
HIGHEST ILATI I DKED
ETSHERIME WA.
LIKEICHEE McKEY A SERIOUS
SHE FINALLYANDE IN JL  10TIS A D
BECAUSE OY S FOUGHTITH
COPS AFTERERATES ARREST
MIND ME OF DANA'S PERFOANCE
VIEW
ALOUGH IT WASN'TPAMHE
SWIPED.
WASAPER TOWE. APPARENT, TYRING
BNTY. LUILY,NE OF THEFFICS WHO
SUBDD HE WAS DESCRIAWNY.
SOY ABOUT THE PER TOW
PUNS.
I GUESS Y COU I'M ON THE
IT GOT ME THINNG ABOUT AKIT
ABOUSPAM
THAN Y'ALL F COMING.
I'M SRIFF BRANDY SCUITS.
AS YOUOW, LAW ENFORMENT IS
WORKIN ORTIME TOEEP OUR
STETS CLE OF E MOST
DAEROUS THGS KWN TOMEN,
FENTANYL, CRYSTALETH AND J
COUL'
COULDN.
ANY ESTIS?
YES.
THIS RIGHTERE THIPAM IS KINGAS ?
WORTH APPROXITELY $350
LLION.
>> YE SHIFF,HAT'S THAT OTHER PIR
OH. THAT'S JUS COINE.
Y'L CAN B ON THA AT THENE POLE
THANYOU.
ROSC GOT THING WITH COKE
CO O
ROSC, LET'S GO.
>> PEOEAUGH ATSPAM BUT
IT --ELL, YOU'RE UP LATE.
YOU' A GAN.
WHEN W THEAST TIM YOU HAD A
SPAM?
>> WELL,OU HE YR KIND OF
PI.
SPAM.
THERS TAT MEATHICH IS A
SPAM VAL.
THE ISOTTED MEAT.
>>YES.
>>ND TRE ARE VIENNA
USAGES. >>O YOREMEMBER THE DILL
HAM THATOULD --
>> S.
SOME -- YOU KNOW,T'SEEN
DECADES BU I C STILL TTE IT
MY MOUTH.
DON'T THK PPLE ARE
STLINGHE SPAM>> NO.
IT'S A PRETTDAMN GOO IT.
WEAPON>>YEAH
>>HE SOND ENDMENT DOE'T
THAT CONTAINER. RK CITY
YOUOT GOOD AI YOUAN
BREAK MEBO'S NOSE WITHHAT
N OFBI-
>> IYOU OPENIT Y KINOF
-- THEOP IELF ISIKE --
>> YEA >> DON EVEN WHAT I S DNG
THERE, REY.
T I'T ITIND OF AIRD, I GUESS, M
SPAM UER GSSSHIS COURY
RIGHW.
YOU KN, ISSAD.
>>AIN, THIS JUS GOE TO
OW.
THES DEMOCRATIC CTROLD
CITIES THAARE ABSUTELY P
YOU KNOW, THI CAT AND
LEAS THIS IAN DANYTHINGAN GET OL
FOUGHT SHANS WHE THEY PUT
THE RSERS ITHE ACTUABOX.
IT'S TRUE
ON, YOU HAVEEOPLEHO ARE
VIOLING OTHER OFFICERS IN THE
SUBW ANDHEY'RE BEING TURD
OUNDND REASE ONAIL AT
THIS WHOLE ST ONRIME LICY
INCREASED INDIVUALLOD IT
CITI.
IT'S INRESTING.
WE'RATCHING T BROKE
NDOW POLICY ACTLLY
PPENG AND Y COU ONLY
BROKEN WINDOW'S POLICY. T
THATF Y JT LET SMALLER
INFRACONSGO, THEJUSTET BIGGER A
KAT.I DIDN'TT'S UNFAIR.
AND I THIN YOUIGHT AGREE WITH
.
THAT WE CL SFF THAT WE GE
IN OUR E-MAIL STU THA WE
DON'TIKESPAMWHY WLD WE -- WHERE
ME FROM?
DID YOU EVERHOUGBOUT THAT?
>> I FORGOTO DO REPT O
TH.
GETOMETHING TO ME NIGHT. >> AB
>>FTER THEOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I HAVE ALL THE TE IN THE WORLD
DO THAT.
I DOT UNRSTAND W THEPUT
ITN PLAST THGH.
>>NO.
STEALINGSPAM, I DON THI N APLAC
U'REOING TGET IN THERE AND
LIKE NOW I C'T TE IT.
YOUUST TAK ITFF AND YOU CAN
AND I THK WT THEY DO -- IT'
JU LE ERYTHING ELSE.
>> THEY ARG IT.
IEENEOPLELLI TOOTHPAE
ONHE STREET.
I HE TO SHAME SEONE FOR
ARTING A SMALL BUSESS.
IT THE ONLY REAN WHY I CAN'T
GET TOOTHPTE.
I JU GET ITN AMAZ.
YOUO OR THERE AND YOU'RE
LIKE I'M GOI TO GET TOOTHPASTE
AND IT' LKED BEHIND AND I
DON'T WANTO BEERE ALL Y.
>> TT'SHE THIN
E ADD KINOF --VERYING
INVOLVE STS.
YOU'RE NEVER AT A -- IN A GOOD
MOODHO YOUR  A PHARMA.
THEY COULDN'TUY ALL THE ONE
PHARCIES BECAUSE TY WOD
ELIMATELL OF THESE EPS.
THEDEAFALKING IN -BEUSEHEY DON'
I EDY SPAM.
AND HAVE T SITND WAIWHIL
TH GO ALL OVEHE PLACEND
>> SP, BTHE WAY, DID COME
IT'S CALLED SPAMMING. ING UNWAN.
>> TERESTING.
I DIDN'TEEDO KNOW THAT.
>> IERELL DAY, BY THE WAY.
FLREE TO COMNTITHE
THE SPAM OR ON TH
SHOPFTING OHE HORRIBLENES
OFOUR FE.
>>TOP .
>> JUS LOVE U.
>> T THINGBOUTHE SPA IS
ME PEOPLAREEALLY EATING
IT
THEY SAL IT BECAUSE IS INSTANTL
ANDOU C TELL WHO WENTO
IL W STEAL IT CAUSE
TH'RE THENES WHO LIKE T
PRIS OD.
WHAT PEOPL WHO EAT I REGULARLY
OBOUSLY CAN'T RERY FAR,YOU KNOW?
>> IATE TO TELYOU,OUGH --
ING R LAW ENFOEMENT.
AND THE WEIT HAS CHAND.
IT'SAMAZING.
TH GOTO GET T FITNESS
OGRA BACK GOIN
IOVE OUR PICE FOE.
THEYOVE ME.
WE ALLET ALONG WELL.
MAYBE THAT'S WH THE ICE
EAMS LOCKED UP.
>> ALLY
>>AH.
FOR GOODN MY NEIGHBOROD. P
WHICAS KT A GOOD 4 POUND
OFF OME.
>> TNK AUT THIS.
AT DOES IT SAYBOUT
DECRAT RUN CIT THAT OUR
AMS ARE LOCKE UPUTHECRIMINAL ART
AND WSHOURAP UP.
FINAY.
FINAY JIMMY SAID SETHI
THAT WE CA ACTUALLY AGREE WI.
AFTE ALL TT NONSENSE.
>>P NEX IS AME